so this is my vow
all gods will die
we've been given a new look at love and
thunder in the form of two newly
released images so let's break it down
so the two images we have here are of
mighty four and four now the first thing
i want to say is that jane foster as my
t4 looks absolutely fantastic darma
really really suits her well and she
looks perfect for the role so they've
done a really good job at designing her
look here now with this first picture
with this purple background and this
white flash of light jane foster and
thor are having a very very intimate
scene here judging by the way they're
looking at each other their body
language and the way the shot is
composed i would say in this movie we'll
see them get back together because as we
know jane foster is thor's x but it
looks like that might change again in
this film because as we know in this
film four has been counting today since
he has last seen jane foster however in
this scene jane says it's been about
three or four years which at first made
me think okay she doesn't really care as
much as four does however this could
mean that jane foster was snapped so she
was part of the blimp so for her it was
about three or four years and for four
it was more um like eight years just an
interesting thought but what do you guys
think let me know in the comment section
below anyway on to the second image
there's not too much to break down in
this image it's mighty four and four
side by side again showcasing that
they're going to be a team in this movie
they're both going to team up together
and both go on an adventure and we know
thor is going to catch freelance along
the way is jane foster going to feel the
same way or in this first image is she
going to decline him guess we'll just
have to wait and see and move that out
of the way that pretty much sums up this
video so if you did enjoy this breakdown
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching